au milieu des années soixante dix le
rock c'était embourgeoisé le rock était
devenu planant remis les années 70 les
chansons duré 15 minutes il y avait des
nappes de synthés qui faisait chier tout
le monde et puis soudain
et soudain actes ou mono le retour à
l'énergie originale du rock à
l'électricité à la violence à la révolte
voici johnny rotten
à
16 heures john et hautaine
les sexpistols dames messieurs comment
ça va c'est qui le traducteur la jeune
daniel bonsoir daniel gross pour thierry
il est où daniel johnny rotten bien
johnny rotten votre vrai nom en fait
c'est jon liden c'est ça que vous voulez
on m'appelait pire que ça oui c'est vrai
alors rothen ça veut dire pourri un
johnny pourri et c'est vrai que votre
nom à la fois même votre nom johnny
rotten et le nom des sex pistols avait
été déposé par votre manager malcolm
mclaren non propriété intellectuelle je
le suis je suis propriétaire de bonnes
je me suis inventé et c'est moi qui suis
là je suis authentique je suis un
individu j'en suis fier mais vous avez
gagné votre nom quand vous avez gagné
votre procès contre mclaren où s'était
jamais effectivement un problème parce
qu'il a prétendu que je n'étais pas
propriétaire de rien c'est comme quand
on essaie de voler la personnalité de
quelqu'un totalement inacceptable ouais
ça va daniel tu suis ça va bien alors on
1976 il ya eu ça donc
ça
c'était le premier disque premier single
des sex pistols en 77 ya eu l'album
never mind the bollocks et en 79 la mort
de sid vicious et c'est bizarre quand
même 20 ans après les sexpistols sont
toujours présents dans nos têtes sont
toujours là on en parle on les écoute
à quoi c'est dû ya plein de groupes
qu'on ait oublié pourquoi les sexpistols
sont toujours les gens ont besoin d'eau
n'était d'autres cantons une quête
on a l'impression qu'on aime le moine
que c'est quelque chose d'absolument ce
nécessaire pour l'humanité vous avez
besoin de gens comme on vous le rappelle
je ne vais pas partir dernière demande
aux femmes
je ne suis pas que blow famille royale
ouais voilà que dieu sauf la reine
voulez vous l'aimez pas beaucoup te
libères que sa peinture de voir la
politique est totalement absurde cette
dictature
il n'y a pas vraiment de 6,2 les règles
c'est très bien mais il faut une
certaine souplesse et sinon ça serait là
c'était dicton quand je vote reporté de
15 cm et qui sont à la base je voudrais
qu'ils fassent ce jeudi une roue je ne
paye pas pro dictature mais est ce que
vous croyez pas que les sexpistols sont
toujours d'actualité parce que on est
toujours dans une époque de nos futurs
finalement l'impression qu'effectivement
le monde est devenu peu morne
est ce que c'est la faute des jeunes
c'est la faute des politiciens
vive la révolution français dans le
texte en français dans le texte merci
dernière
alors johnny rotten de poids est mort le
groupe les sexpistols pourquoi ça s'est
arrêté pourquoi ça a duré aussi peu de
temps pour les bonnes raisons mais
c'était sur le plan affectif sur le plan
physique ils ensemble il ya eu des
jalousies heureusement la drogue aussi
je trie des grands pense qu'il ne faut
pas qu'on dise de ne pas le faire mais
il faut que l'éducation est la base la
connaissance chacun pour avoir la
possibilité de faire des choix des choix
raisonnable l'individu c'est mon droit
d'être toxicomanes et j'ai choisi de ne
pas l'être mais est-ce qu'à l'époque
vous en preniez pas non plus à l'époque
des sex pistols il ya 20 ans ou 25 ans
vous en preniez pas non plus comme tout
bon c'est pas tout ça mais on essayait
plutôt de prendre les amphétamines
peut-être pour m'écrire inhalé de
l'amafar bien sûr et alors vous faites
quoi aujourd'hui johnny rotten dans
votre vie a donc je vais sur de
télévision jetez plus donc je dis ce que
je pense que les maisons de disques que
c'est fini on n'en a plus besoin c'est
comme les gouvernements même destinée
ordonne du canut de date
oui je peux faire tout ce que vous
voulez comme annexe que si vous payez
comptablement bien sûr non parce que
petit à petit je voulais voir un petit
peu des niches ou alors vous êtes en
français johnny rotten pour la sortie du
film de julian tempel qui s'appelle
l'obscénité et la fureur
ce soir je viens d'y assister la réponse
a été extraordinaire
voilà je suis venu essayer de notre
gueule alors c'est le deuxième film de
julien de tempel sur les sex pistols le
premier avait été sapée la grande
escroquerie du rock'n'roll était plutôt
favorable à votre manager le premier
malcolm mclaren non la grande
escroquerie c'est et puis tout ce qu'ils
voulaient faire c'était un petit peu de
la fantaisie c'est la réalité
moi je préfère la réalité
malheureusement je pense que l'histoire
devrait être précise je n'ai pas besoin
que tous ses fantasmes
sauf chez moi oui alors d'où viennent
tempel qui a réalisé le film a une
théorie sur la mort de sites vicieux
qu'il ait exprimé il ya quelques temps
dans le new musical express il dit en
fait qu'elle son avis et sylvie cious
n'est pas mort d'une overdose
accidentelle mais il s'est suicidé parce
qu'en fait il n'était pas du tout
coupable de la mort de 26
une gueule qui était arrivé quatre mois
avant dans un hôtel à new york c'est une
possibilité que je ne sais pas exception
et je n'aime pas modifié
c'est une tragédie quand quelqu'un meurt
à l'essai deux personnes sont mortes
malsain ce n'est pas bon du tout pour
les sexpistols mais peut-être que ça
sera bon pour l'humanité alors
aujourd'hui johnny rotten après toutes
ces années
est ce que vous êtes plutôt ça
what do you prefer de bosses à 201 et
frites avec moi je veux tout pour
m'amuser
et
hop là bas
et si vous aviez un message adressé au
monde ce soir et aspects on est mais ont
dit les juges et personne ne soyez pas
comme ça mais ne soyez pas de super pas
le troupeau
qu'est ce que ça signifie pour vous
jacques higelin et sex pistols j'ai aimé
ça profondément quoi parce que je
trouvais que ça roupille est vraiment et
que ça devenait comme un star system et
être donné chiant le rock'n'roll aussi
c'était comme quelque chose qui
s'endormait toi ça tenait comme c'était
complètement récupéré moi j'ai trouvé ça
comme une bouffée d'air frais j'ai pas
vu du tout dans ce mouvement là quelque
chose de de malsain un nid de
destructeur j'ai trouvé quelque chose d'
extrêmement constructif moi quand j'ai
entendu aussi bien les plages que les
sex pistols que plein d'autres groupes
j'ai trouvé que c'était un renouveau
extraordinaire et que c'était des poètes
des poètes dans le sens noble du terme
est clair et avec un langage extrêmement
clair et combatif et que c'était
vraiment nécessaire et ils ont tellement
tourné en dérision l'établissement toute
cette merde je dois dire que j'ai trouvé
ça bien et courageux et puis c'était
beau quoi c'est un vrai combat je
souhaite qu'une chose c'est ses revenus
un peu avec le rap mais c'est en train
de se faire récupérer par les grosses
bagnoles et avec un mât shit machisme
que je trouve assez nul au niveau d'une
évolution de l'humanité qu'est ce que ça
signifie pour vous les laissez qu'ils
puissent 75
non j'étais pas tout petits à tanger je
suis né en 63 un gta doute aux étrangers
c'était mon idole c'est incroyable que
je sois à côté de lui c'est fou ça fait
drôle c'est incroyable parce que j'étais
à l'époque j'avais la même coupe de
cheveux puis je parler moins bien
anglais avec lui mais
non qu'est ce qui est arrivé à bochum
areva les risques at elle dit en
connaissez l'expression non seulement
j'étais hyper loin mais je n'étais même
pas né
ah ouais non c'était vraiment bah ouais
je suis vraiment un gros bébé mon gros
plus des marques de sondes il mais bon
maintenant j'apprends on est là pour
apprendre et heureusement cliniciens et
vous les enfants ça vous rappelle quoi
c'est bien mais c'est pas ça vaut pas
quand même plastic bertrand colin
johanson
j'ai bien aimé la chanson voyage voyage
moi je suis je pense qu'ils aient le
français à l'époque pour vous c'était
des bouffons bien c'était différent
c'était
un petit peu connu mais sont quand même
des comics même aussi fait que cela
autant que d'autres choses parce que
sans le bourg ça ne sert à rien tout ça
et que je vienne jour les comédiens sont
les plus délictuelle finalement allé
dire que les comédiens comédiennes en
anglais ça veut dire comme où les comics
emon voilà bravo hein
alors est ce que vous savez johnny
rotten qu'on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle droite
[Musique]
m
c'est bien même johnny rotten pourtant
ça autant c'est un pote tu vois ma fille
tu vois ma fille m'aime johnny rotten ne
bouge pas dans le 10e dans ta révolution
bien d'ailleurs le jeu saw j'ai dû
quelques emails une fille qui s'appelle
pâte lamberti qui me dit sa révolution
en coûte cher à bafiba oui il est
toujours pas là fred b qui donc veut
faire son site sur les gens qui veulent
bouger les baptistes puis à quelques
opposants il ya un mec qui s'appelle
vincent gaillard qui a viré sa fiancée
clair parce qu'elle bougeait par le
jingle foule mais qui virent leur gueule
et il y en a d'autres comme mourad à
base qui dit moi je doute je bouge pas
par un jingle parce que toute façon je
suis bien au chaud sous ma couette et
alors là il ya une fille qui dit elle
s'appelle floriane elle dit si j'enlève
un vêtement à chaque jingle est-ce que
je peux bouger
la réponse est oui dérogation spéciale
alors on va faire avec jenny rothen une
interview anti portrait chinois
daniel difficile à expliquer le portrait
chinois c'est si vous étiez une fleur
qu'est ce que vous seriez comme fleurs
je serai un mieux autisme et l'anti
portrait chinois c'est si vous étiez une
maladie donc johnny rotten if you were
10 is what kind of disease would you be
je serai là peste parce que je ressemble
à un rap par la peste
si vous étiez une injure suite il ne
jure ouais ça veut dire saisir cours
daniel et ses parts dans le traducteur
et c'est un espèce de brigands aulas la
bagnole et for use in bann transiger
mais qu'on provoque non je ferai du
porno très bien gagner
belinda est peut-être plus rapidement si
vous étiez un accident je serai en
ambulance si vous étiez une guerre
troisième gardien si vous étiez un vis à
vis si vous étiez un supplice je pense
que d'une certaine manière musicalement
je le suis les vaches mondiale
c'est bien si vous étiez une cicatrice
score cicatrices anales un poison
personnes à oman à la salmonelle j'aime
bien les salmonelles fumée si vous étiez
un [ __ ] beaucoup dirais que je suis
déjà si vous étiez un assassin n'y
aurait pas de problème de gestion je
pense c'est ya un virus quelque chose
sur internet
l avion à l'avenir je vais aussi
l'appétit
si vous étiez un dictateur à eau
je suis je courais d'une certaine
manière d'un dictateur espagnol parce
que ça devient pire dictateur de bouche
espagnol moustiques espagnol vous si
vous étiez un terroriste la guerre mais
je le suis avec a demandé à la famille
royale britannique qui le connaissent
très bien et si vous étiez la mort quel
genre de mort seriez vous donne par deux
roues ça c'est quelque chose que je
n'entends pas je suis sourd tout d'un
coup
bravo génie
ils portent des chinois c'est vrai
qu'avec lui c'est vrai qu'à avec vous
l'anti portrait chinois c'est gagné
d'avancé quoi yocum vous revenez dans 20
ans ah ah non mais j'espère j'espère que
nous ne serons plus là
oui bah écoutez si vous m'invitez génial
il va fait il m'a fait ce que calais
olivier ont fait à vous arrêter la même
chose
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux